what I want to do in this video is give
you at least a basic overview of
probability probability a word that
you've probably heard a lot of and you
are probably a little bit familiar with
it but hopefully this will give you a
little deeper understanding so let's say
that I have let's say that I have a fair
coin over here and so when I talk about
a fair coin I mean that it has an equal
chance of landing on one side or another
so you can maybe view it as the sides
are equal the weight is the same on
either side it's not if I flip it in the
air it's not more likely to land on one
side or the other it's equally likely
and so you have one side of this coin so
this would be the heads I guess try to
draw try to draw George Washington I'll
assume it's a quarter of some kind and
then the other side of course is the
tails so that is heads the other side
right over there is tails and so if I
were to ask you what is the probability
I'm going to flip a coin I'm going to
flip a coin and I want to know what is
the probability of getting heads and I
could write that like this the
probability of getting heads and you
probably just based on that question
have a sense of what probability is
asking it's asking for some type of some
type of way of getting your hands around
an event that's fundamentally random we
don't know whether it's heads or tails
but we can start to describe the chances
of it being heads or tails and we'll
talk about different ways of describing
that so one way to think about it and
this is the way the probability tends to
be introduced in textbooks as you say
well look how many different equally
likely possibilities are there so how
many equally likely possibilities so
number of equally let me write equally
of equally likely equally likely
possibilities possibilities and of the
number of equally possibilities I care
about the number that have that contain
my event right here so the number of
possibilities possibilities that meet my
constraint
that meet my conditions that meet my
conditions so in the case of the
probability of figuring out heads what
is the number of equally likely
possibilities well there's only two
possibilities we're just not we're
assuming that the coin can't land on its
corner and just stand straight up we're
assuming that it lands flat so there's
two possibilities here
two equally likely possibilities you
could either get heads or you could get
tails and what's the number of
possibilities that meet my conditions
well there's only one the condition of
heads so it'll be one over two so the
one way to think about it is the
probability of getting heads is equal to
one over two is equal to one-half if I
wanted to write that as a percentage we
know that 1/2 is the same thing as 50%
now another way to think about or
conceptualize probability that will give
you this exact same answer is to say
well if I were to run the experiment of
flipping a coin
so this flip you view this as an
experiment I know this is a kind of
experiment that you're used to you know
you'd only think an experiment is doing
something with in chemistry or physics
or all the rest but an experiment is
every time you do you run this random
event so one way to think about
probability is if I were to do this
experiment an experiment many many many
times if I do it a thousand times or a
million times or a billion times or
trillion times and the more the better
what percentage of those would give me
what I care about what percentage of
those would give me heads and so another
way to think about this 50 percent
probability of getting heads is if I
were to run this experiment tons of
times if I were to run this forever
though and closer or an infinite number
of times what percentage of those would
be heads you would get this 50 percent
and you can run that simulation you can
flip a coin and it's actually a fun
thing to do I encourage you to do it if
you put take a hundred or two hundred
quarters or penny stick them in a big
box shake the box so you're kind of
simultaneously flipping all of the quote
all of the coins and then count how many
of those are going to be heads and
you're going to see that the larger the
number that you are you are you
are doing the more likely you're going
to get something really close to 50%
there's always some chance even if you
flip the coin a million times there's
some SuperDuper small chance that you
get all tails but the more you do the
more likely that you're going to get
you're going to that things are going to
trend towards 50% of them are going to
be heads now let's just apply these same
ideas and write well we're starting with
probability cut at least kind of the
basic this is probably an easier thing
to conceptualize but a lot of times this
is actually a helpful one to this idea
that if you run the experiment many many
many many times what percentage of those
trials are going to give you what you're
asking for in this case it was heads now
let's do another very typical example
when you first learn probability and
this is the idea of rolling a die so
here's my die right over here and of
course you have you know you have the
different sides of the die so that's the
one that's the two that's the three and
what I want to do and we know of course
that there are and I'm assuming this is
a fair die and so there are six equally
likely possibilities you could when you
roll this you could get a 1 a 2 a 3 a 4
a 5 or 6 and they are all equally likely
so if I were to ask you what is the
probability what is the probability
given that I'm rolling a fair die so the
experiment is rolling this fair die what
is the probability of getting a 1 well
what are the number of equally likely
possibilities well I have six equally
likely possibilities and how many of
those meet my conditions well only one
of them meets my condition that right
there so there is a 1/6 probability of
rolling a 1 what is the probability what
is the probability of rolling a 1 or a 6
well once again there are six equal
equally there are six equally likely
possibilities for what I can get and
there's two there are now two
possibilities that meet my conditions I
could roll a 1 or I could roll a 6 so
now there's two equally likely
possibilities that meet my constraints
my conditions so
this is there's a 1/3 probability of
rolling a 1 or a 6 now what is what is
the probability this might seem a little
silly to even ask this question but I'll
ask it just to make it clear what is the
probability of rolling a 2 & 2 and a 3
and I'm just talking about one roll of
the die well in any roll of the die I
can only get a 2 or a 3 I'm not talking
about taking two rolls of this die so in
this situation it is there's six there
are six possibilities but none of these
possibilities are two and a three
none of these are two and a three two
and three cannot exist on one trial you
cannot get a two and a three in the same
in the same experiment these are getting
a 2 and a 3 are mutually exclusive
events they cannot happen at the same
time so the probability of this is
actually 0 there's no way to roll this
normal die and all of a sudden you get a
2 and a 3 in fact and I don't want to
confuse you with that because it's just
you know it's kind of abstracted
impossible so let's cross this out right
over here now what is the probability
what is the probability of getting an
even number of getting an even number so
once again you have six equally likely
possibilities when I roll that die and
which of these which of these
possibilities meet my conditions the
condition of being even well 2 is even 4
is even and 6 is even so three of the
possibilities meet my conditions meet my
constraints so this is one half if I
roll a die I have a 1/2 chance of
getting an even number